VOICE THAT DESERVES TO BE HEARD
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
OUR NEXT GUEST HAS FOUGHT
RELENTLESSLY AGAINST MEDICAL
CARTELS SILENCING CAMPAIGN WHICH
IS WHY HE INVITED PEOPLE LIKE
MICHELLE AND ACTUAL EXPERTS TO
JOIN HIM IN FLORIDA TODAY AND IS
ALSO CALLING FOR A GRAND JURY
NOW TO INVESTIGATE ANY AND ALL
WRONG DOING IN FLORIDA WITH
RESPECT TO THE COVID-19
VACCINES.
JOINING US NOW IS FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
GOVERNOR, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN TODAY IN
HEARING, AGAIN, THESE VOICES,
MANY OF THEM SUPPRESSED OR
PEOPLE OSTRACIZED OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS?
>> WELL, LAURA, LIKE ANYTHING, I
MEAN, YOU TAKE AN MRNA SHOT AND
THE WAY TO VIEW IT IS, OKAY,
WHAT ARE THE BENEFITS AND WHAT
ARE THE DRAW BACKS.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE OUR MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT NEVER WANTED TO BE
HONEST WITH PEOPLE ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL DRAW BACKS.
SO YOU SHOWED A CLIP FROM A
DOCTOR DOWN HERE IN FLORIDA AND
THE ANALYSIS THAT HE'S DONE WITH
PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY YOUNG MEN
WHO HAVE TAKEN THE MRNA SHOTS.
WE, OF COURSE, HAD WITNESSES
TALK ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE.
AND HOW ARE WE IN A SITUATION,
YES, FLORIDA, WE BANNED VACCINE
PASSPORTS ALMOST TWO YEARS AGO.
WE BANNED THE SHOT MANDATES FOR
JOBS AND SAVED A LOT OF PEOPLE'S
JOBS.
NEVERTHELESS, THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY, YOU STILL HAVE HUNDREDS
OF UNIVERSITIES IN OTHER STATES
THAT ARE STILL MANDATING THESE
BOOSTERS ON THESE COLLEGE KIDS.
WHEN ANY TYPE OF COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS WOULD SAY THE BENEFIT
FOR THEM TAKING THE SHOT, AS YOU
ALLUDED TO, IT DOESN'T PREVENT
THEM FROM GETTING INFECTED OR
SPREADING IT ANYWAYS.
THE BENEFIT IS MINUSCULE.
BUT, AS JOE LATAPOE AND OTHER
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THERE IS A
RISK FOR DOING IT.
SO WHY CAN'T OUR MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT ACKNOWLEDGE THAT?
WHY THE DECEPTION AND WHY HAVE
THEY CONTINUED TO DO THIS FOR
TWO YEARS.
>> Laura: I WANT TO READ SOME OF
THE REACTION TO YOUR MOVE TODAY.
NEW YORK MAGAZINE'S JONATHAN
CHATS SAID IT'S VERY OBVIOUS RON
DeSANTIS IS COURTING THE ANTI
VACCINE MOVEMENTS, IT'S
INTELLECTUAL DYSFUNCTION SIMILAR
FROM VANITY AFFAIR TAKING YOUR
AUTHORITARIAN TO NEXT LEVELS.
GOVERNOR IS YOUR GOAL WITH THIS
ROUND TABLE TODAY TO DEMONIZE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
OFFICIALS?
>> LET ME TELL YOU THIS, LAURA.
THE AUTHORITARIANS WERE THE ONES
THAT WANTED TO MANDATE THE VAX
ON PEOPLE.
I PROTECTED PEOPLE FROM HAVING
THAT HAPPEN AND MADE SURE
FLORIDIANS COULD MAKE THEIR OWN
CHOICE.
THE AUTHORITARIANS WANTED TO
INSTITUTE A VACCINE PASSPORT
SYSTEM, ALMOST LIKE A SOCIAL
CREDIT SYSTEM, SO THAT PEOPLE
WHO DISSENTED FROM THIS WOULD BE
MARGINALIZED FROM SOCIETY
ENTIRELY.
WE REJECTED THAT AND WE BANNED
IT.
SO WE WERE, FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, YOU KNOW, HELPING
PEOPLE MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS,
BUT NOT USING EITHER THE
COERCIVE POWER OF THE STATE OR
ALLOWING BIG CORPORATIONS TO
CONDITION THOSE CHOICES.
AND SO, LOOK, AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
TO PROVIDE TRUTH, TO PROVIDE
ACCURATE DATA AND TO PROVIDE
ACCURATE ANALYSIS.
AND WE HAD A GREAT RESEARCHER
FROM DENMARK.
YOU KNOW, LAURA, DENMARK DOES
NOT ALLOW PEOPLE UNDER 50,
UNLESS THEY HAVE PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, TO GET THE MRNA
SHOTS BECAUSE THEY'VE ANALYZED
IT AND SAID THAT THE DRAW BACKS
OUTWEIGH THE BENEFITS.
BUT THEY'VE ALSO LOOKED AT
ALL-CAUSE MORTALITY AND THE
RESEARCHER FOUND THAT YES, IN
SOME AGE GROUPS THERE WAS A
DECLINE IN COVID MORTALITY AFTER
TAKING THESE BUT THEN THERE WAS
AN INCREASE IN OTHER TYPES OF
MORTALITY.
SO WHY HAVE WE NOT SEEN BIG
DECLINES IN EXCESS MORTALITY
SINCE THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED?
SO WE HAVE NOW A PANEL THAT
WE'VE CREATED IN FLORIDA THAT IS
EFFECTIVELY GOING TO FUNCTION
THE WAY A CDC SHOULD FUNCTION
AND BASICALLY DO EVIDENCE-BASED
MEDICINE, TAKE STUDIES SERIOUSLY
THAT COUNTERACT THE NARRATIVE.
AND BE WILLING TO ASK QUESTIONS
AND GOING WHERE THE DATA LEADS.
>> Laura: AND GOVERNOR ON
ANOTHER ISSUE, TODAY IN
WASHINGTON, THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
CELEBRATING THE PRESIDENT
SIGNING OF A NATIONAL
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT BOTH
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE AND
NON-TRADITIONAL MARRIAGES, GAY
MARRIAGE, AND THE LIKE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF RELIGIOUS
CONSERVATIVES AND OTHER
TRADITIONAL AMERICANS WHO ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS WILL END UP
BEING A SEVERE ENCROACHMENT ON
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY AND RELIGIOUS
CONSCIOUS RIGHTS AND I WONDER IF
YOU MIGHT HAVE A REACTION TO
THOSE CONCERNS.
>> I THINK THEY'RE VALID
CONCERNS.
I MEAN, LAURA, WAS INTERRACIAL
MARRIAGE BEING EVEN DEBATED IN
THIS COUNTRY?
NOBODY'S TALKING ABOUT THAT.
THEY'RE USING THE POWER, I
THINK, OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN WAYS THAT WILL ABSOLUTELY PUT
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS IN
DIFFICULT SPOTS IF YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SO INCLINED TO
BE VERY AGGRESSIVE AGAINST THAT.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT IT WAS --
THERE WAS CERTAINLY NO NEED TO
DO THIS AND I DO THINK THAT
THOSE CONCERNS WERE VALID.
>> Laura: AND THE OTHER ISSUE
BREWING HERE WHICH WILL AFFECT
ALL THE STATES, WHICH IS THIS
OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL WORKING
ITS WAY THROUGH THE SENATE WITH
MITCH McCONNELL LOOKING LIKE HE
WANTS TO STRIKE A DEAL WITH
CHUCK SCHUMER.
LOT OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS WE WANT
TO TALK TO ONE NOT HAPPY BECAUSE
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY TAKING OVER
THE HOUSE IN A FEW WEEKS MEANING
NO LEVERAGE FOR THE REPUBLICANS
GOING FORWARD.
I KNOW YOU'RE NOT IN CONGRESS
ANYMORE, BUT YOU HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE HAVING BEEN A
CONGRESSMAN.
WHAT WOULD YOUR REEKS BE IF YOU
WERE STILL UP ON CAPITOL HILL
AND YOU JUST LOST ALL THAT
LEVERAGE NEXT YEAR.
>> OBVIOUSLY THEY SHOULD PUNT IT
TO THE NEW CONGRESS WHEN WE'LL
HAVE THE MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE.
THERE WILL BE MORE REPUBLICAN
LEVERAGE AND THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
HOPEFULLY ENGINEER A BETTER
OUTCOME THAN THEY WILL BEING IN
THE MINORITY IN BOTH HOUSES
RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: WHY DO YOU THINK THE
REPUBLICANS WOULD NOT WANT TO DO
THAT?
KEVIN MCCARTHY OR WHOEVER WOULD
BE SPEAKER?
WHY DO YOU THINK?
>> LAURA, YOU'RE LOOKING TO A
GUY THAT HAS VOTED AGAINST
OMNIBUS BILLS IN MY SLEEP WHEN I
WAS IN CONGRESS.
I MEAN, THAT'S JUST THE WAY
THESE GUYS OPERATE.
I NEVER FIT INTO THAT AND PART
OF THE REASON I RAN FOR
GOVERNOR, QUITE FRANKLY, IS
BECAUSE I DIDN'T LIKE THE WAY
WASHINGTON OPERATED.
BUT, YEAH, YOU HAVE REALLY BOTH
PARTIES HAVE BEEN ADDICTED TO
THESE BIG OMNIBUS BILLS THEY'LL
PUT IT OUT THOUSANDS OF PAGES NO
ONE WILL READ IT AND IT'S
BASICALLY BACK TO NANCY PELOSI
GOVERNMENT, PASS IT TO FIND
WHAT'S IN IT.
AND I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE SICK OF THAT.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, WE
REALLY ENJOYED THE ROUND TABLE
TODA